good evening my fellow americans
now before i begin i just want to say
that i know a lot of people out there
seem to think that i don't get angry
that's just not true i get angry a lot
it's just that the way i express passion
is different from most
so just so there's no more confusion
we've hired luther here to be my anger
translator luther
first off concerning the recent
developments in the middle eastern
region
i just want to reiterate our unflinching
support for all people
and their right to a democratic process
hey all y'all dictators out there
keep messing around and see what happens
just see what happens
watch also to the governments of iran
and north korea uh we once again urge
you to discontinue your uranium
enrichment program hey mahmoud
kim jong i think i already done told
both y'all 86 your [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'ma come over there and do it for y'all
please test me
and see what happens on the domestic
front
uh i just want to say to my critics i
hear your voices
and i'm aware of your concerns so maybe
if you can chill the hell out for like a
second
then maybe i can focus on some [ __ ] you
know
that goes for everybody uh including
members of the tea party
don't even get me started on these
[ __ ] right here i want to
assure you
that we will be looking for new
compromises with the gop
in the months ahead and you know these
[ __ ] gonna say no before i even
suggest some [ __ ]
now i know a lot of folks
say that i haven't done a good job at
communicating my accomplishments to the
public
because y'all [ __ ] don't listen
uh
since being in office we've created
three million new jobs
three million new jobs we ended the war
in iraq and the war y'all we ended a war
remember
that these achievements should serve as
a reminder that
i am on your side i am not a muslim
and that my intentions as your president
are coming from the right place
they're coming from hawaii which is
where i'm from which is in the united
states of america y'all
okay this is ridiculous i have a birth
certificate
i have a birth certificate i have a hot
diggity
doggity mama say my massamu microsoft
birth certificate your dumb ass crackers
okay
luther yep rope it in yeah dolly back
luther damn
in conclusion uh last night i had a
conversation with michelle
nope i did not say that i did not say
[Music]
that
[Music]
twitter